más filtraciones en Colombia y
nuevamente el ex embajador en Venezuela
Armando Benedetti y la ex jefa de
gabinete Laura Sarabia en el centro por
primera vez el presidente Gustavo Petro
se refirió al escándalo en Twitter yo no
acepto chantajes ni veo la política como
un espacio de favores personales aquí
estoy solo para lograr más justicia
social en mi país es eso lo que me mueve
y obsesiona si hay personas en otra
lógica diferente en el gobierno es mejor
que se separen de él fue su respuesta
tras la publicación de la revista semana
de varios audios de Benedetti para Laura
Sarabia aburrido en Venezuela el ex
embajador quería más protagonismo en el
gobierno de Petro pero tras un retraso
de más de tres horas para reunirse con
el presidente estalló contra Sarabia que
trabajó cinco años para él
qué tal que uno diga mamando gallo Quién
fue el que puso la plata aquí en la
costa nos hundimos todos nos acabamos
todos nos vamos presos para el abogado
constitucionalista Juan Carlos Cherry en
France 24 estas filtraciones van a
marcar el gobierno de Petro Entonces yo
creo que sin duda vendrán las
descalificaciones y explicaciones de la
información vendrán Las investigaciones
judiciales y ahora intentos por
recuperar la legitimidad tratando de que
el equipo de gobierno muestre coherencia
y muestre que es eficiente y eficaz en
la gestión Sarabia y Benedetti fueron
clave para la victoria de Petro en 2022
tras ganar la presidencia Sarabia se
convirtió en jefa de gabinete mientras
Petro envió a Benedetti a Venezuela para
alejarle del primer plano por sus
escándalos su enfado coincide con la
filtración del robo de un bolso con
varios miles de dólares de la niñera de
Laura Sarabia que también lo había sido
de los hijos de Benedetti la niñera
habría sido interrogada con polígrafo e
interceptada telefónicamente la
oposición demanda explicaciones mientras
desde el gobierno señalan al fiscal y a
una conspiración de la oposición para
frenar las reforma